solitude is a big part of my story about
reclaiming conversation and some people
say well why is that I mean solitude
conversation with claiming conversation
begins in solitude and here's why
that you need to be able to gather
yourself to yourself and have a capacity
for solitude before you can turn to
someone else and really hear what they
have to say because if not if you don't
have a capacity for solitude you turn to
someone else and you're projecting onto
them who you need them to be for you and
you can't hear who they really are and
instinctively we shun people like that
and you know technically there are
narcissistic personalities but we don't
need to know we don't need to know their
technical name we just we just know
we're uncomfortable about them because
they're not giving us a chance to be us
they're they're making us be who they
need who they need us to be and so a
capacity for solitude is really the
first step in a capacity for
relationship and so solitude and the
capacity for relationship solitude and a
capacity for conversation these go
together
now solitude is one of the things that
constantly go into your phone is is
taking away from us there's a there's a
study a dramatic study it was going to
make a bad pun and say a stunning study
I think in reclaiming conversation I
actually made this pun unintentionally
and now I feel I sort of have to
apologize for it but we're college
students are asked to just sit in a
chair the way I'm sitting in a chair
without a book and without a device and
they're told that they're gonna be asked
to do that for six to fifteen minutes
and when the study begins they're asked
do you think you'll want to give
yourself electroshocks during this time
and like they say oh absolutely not
no after sick
minutes they're giving themselves
electroshocks rather than sit quietly
with their own thoughts in our culture
so used to being able to go to a device
we treat being alone as a problem that
needs to be solved and we want to solve
it with technology and we do solve it
with technology and when people say to
me oh there's nothing new Under the Sun
we've always had books we've always had
television we've always had something
something something you know isn't this
just the same old same old I say you
know what no no actually not we've never
had a device that could turn us away
from other people just by going like
this and all of a sudden you're in your
own private space with a world of other
people on your phone and we've never had
a device where you could be taking a
walk in the woods and you didn't need to
be taking a walk in the woods and and
this is a new challenge for us to
recognize how much we need solitude and
to reclaim it so that we can reclaim
conversation